le premier sentiment mais c'est
certainement le plus important c'est un
sentiment de satisfaction au sens où
cette mission défense frôle les 41
milliards d'euros fin vous préciserez le
chiffre ce qui est conforme à la
trajectoire qui était programmée dans la
lpm et donc nous nous réjouissons bien
sûr du respect de ces marches à 1
milliard sept depuis quatre ans et je
souhaite ici en donner acte aux
gouvernements nous savons bien que
il y aura des années peut-être un peu
plus compliqué puisque lpm prévoyez
démarche à 3 milliards d'euros
je vais dire qu on les examinera en
temps voulu mais vous savez que c'est un
un souci permanent du sénat souci que je
souhaite te il soit compris comme étant
un souci positif car une nouvelle bm
nous en avons souvent discuté est fait
pour être appliqué dans sa totalité même
si bien évidemment des modifications en
cours de route peuvent intervenir mais
il faut pas relâcher l'effort parce
qu'on voit bien gelée vu dans le les
contacts que j'ai eus avec les nouveaux
chefs d'états-majors que le aussi
souhaite que c'était fort soit soient
poursuivis d'un autre côté ça nous
comprenons bien que l'impact de la
pandémie aura à un moment ou un autre
quelques conséquences mais nous nous
verrons cela dans les années suivantes
pour l'instant nous sommes sur un
constat de satisfaction globale sur le
milliard sept qui s'ajoute au budget
ce respect de la programmation globale
ne nous dispense pas évidemment de nous
interroger sur les redéploiements de
crédits opérer c'est du reste le premier
exercice qui en tient compte ce sont des
redéploiements qui je le rappelle ont
été introduits et identifié suite à
l'actualisation de la revue stratégique
par revenir sur la question du périmètre
de l'actualisation dont nous avions
débattu il ya de cela quelques mois
j'observe que conformément à vos
engagements une première réunion de
travail s'est tenue
entre votre cabinet plusieurs de nos
rapporteur ce qui doit permettre
d'éclairer
les points de frottement qui avait pu
naître au moment de ce débat et je redis
encore ici devant nos collègues que la
meilleure méthode c'est celle là qui
consiste à travailler cartes sur table à
s'expliquer cet as a été reporté parce
que moi j'étais pas là hier soir donc la
réunion est reportée parce que oui il ya
eu des collègues qui ne pouvait pas s'y
rendre parce qu'ils
arrivent à la fin y ait eu un changement
d'horaire bon
donc en tous les cas la réunion va avoir
lieu le principe reste le même et nous
sommes très attachés à cette cet échange
techni j'allais dire qui permet de
comparer les analyses qu'on fait mes
collègues rapporteur et
vos collaborateurs
alors ce budget 2022 et donc j'ai dit le
premier budget postérieure aux
ajustements qui ont été décidées en 2021
vous nous direz bien évidemment comme
ils se traduisent concrètement dans la
loi de dans la loi de finances notamment
sur les sujets que l'on suit
particulièrement notamment le
renseignement le domaine de l'espace et
du cyber qui ont été identifiés comme
prioritaires et ce matin dans une
audition j'allais dire australienne nous
recevions bernard emié le patron de la
dgse et qui soulignait lui aussi toute
l'importance qu'il y à maintenir
l'effort en matière de renseignements où
nous devons garder nos positions pour
les raisons que tout le monde a
maintenant compris plus généralement
comment peut-on rester leader dans les
domaines technologiques de pointe en
conservant une
modèle d'armée complet et en se
préparant à l'hypothèse de la haute
intensité
qui reste une priorité compte tenu de la
dangerosité constante du monde qui nous
entoure est ce que nous sommes capables
d'atteindre tous ses objectifs conformes
simultanément dans l'enveloppé nous
avions défini ensemble en 2018 vous ne
le précise ray bien sûr 7
cette loi de programme c'est cet
exercice budgétaire tient compte aussi
de la dégradation d'un contexte
stratégique qui ne cesse de se confirmer
on le voit et on combien les etats-unis
concentrent maintenant leur attention
sur l'inde au pacifique le retour
précipité d'afghanistan la conclusion de
l'accord rochus
tout ceci doit nous inciter à
prendre la mesure des changements qui
interviennent dans ce domaine est plus
que jamais le tenue mi stratégique
européenne s'impose on voit du reste des
déclarations qui commence à bouger et
notamment au sein de nos partenaires
européens
est-ce qu'on finira par convaincre
nombre d'entre eux là nous souhaitons
que cette présidence française de
l'union permet d avancer je rappelle que
c'est ici du reste 25 février prochain
que le sénat français accueillera les
vannes six autres parlements justement
sur une table ronde à une journée de
travail sur l'autonomie stratégique
pour essayer de partager nos analyses
sachant que nous même et je me compte
dedans nous entamons un travail de
diplomatie parlementaire soit en
accueillant soit en visitant nos
homologues je serai moi même et quelques
collègues en
je profiterai de l'assemblée de sommet
de l'otan à lisbonne déjà pourvoir nous
nous équivalent nos collègues portugais
puis à varsovie qui est aussi ce
qui est aussi un interlocuteur important
et qui a souhaité nous rencontrer sur
ces sujets ce qui est plutôt une bonne
chose
nous sommes évidemment un peu inquiet de
coopération
qui nous pose deux questions celle avec
le royaume uni à la fois après le break
6 et puis après hocus une car ces
relations
ne sont pas en meilleure forme et puis
bien sûr nous attendons la constitution
de la coalition suite aux élections
allemandes pour voir comment vont
pouvoir être poursuivis les programmes
que nous menons en commun vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots mais
peut-être en guise d'introduction avant
de revenir au but chez
sur roger et fait part de ses talents
peut-être peu
c'était juste pour nous dérider à un
moment où je n'ai abordé un sujet
dramatique puisque je voulais que vous
nous disiez un mot sur le mali où en
sommes-nous en ça peut-être en question
d'actualité j'avais dit on pour débuter
c'est quand même très important que vous
explosif ce que vous avez des contacts
récents avec la junte pour savoir
notamment ce qu'il en est de ces milices
wagner et de la situation dans laquelle
nous nous retrouverons notre nous
pourrions nous retrouver si par malheur
la junte malienne conclu un accord avec
ses milices et puis après donc on peut
en ont peut poursuivre sur cette
présentation du budget je rappelle que
ces auditions fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo sous connaissez un
ministre piteuse de travail je vous
laisse la parole qu'à prendre un échange
avec l'ensemble de nos collègues
vous avez la parole vous
m'autorisez bien
j'ai bien noté la question sur le mali
je me propose la garder pour y répondre
dans les premières questions qui me
seront adressés afin de pouvoir démarrer
sur l'objet de notre audition qui est la
présentation du budget c'est donc une
rendez vous au traditionnel aux
automnales qui me permet avec plaisir
mais aussi avec une certaine émotion de
vous présenter ce budget du ministère
des armées pour la cinquième fois et
donc pour ce qui me concerne la dernière
en tant que ministre des armées
j'aimerais donc en profiter tout d'abord
pour vous remercier et remercier
l'ensemble des rapporteurs
qui par leur contribution au cours des
derniers mois et des dernières années on
nous ont aidés à tenir le cap vous êtes
un soutien essentiel et directe à la
modernisation de nos armées
si nous parvenons en effet améliorer la
qualité et le quotidien de nos forces
c'est aussi grâce à vos travaux et puis
au dialogue que vous entretenez avec les
civils et les militaires du ministère
alors comme moi vous pensez certainement
qu'un budget ce n'est pas qu'un tableau
de ligne et deux colonnes un budget
c'est d'abord et avant tout une réponse
une réponse aux attentes des femmes et
des hommes de la défense une réponse aux
menaces qui pèsent sur la france est une
réponse aux défis qui nous attendent
dans les prochaines années et donc si
vous me permettez je me livrerai un très
rapide retour en arrière je me remettrai
our placerait dans la position
que j'ai trouvé lorsque je suis arrivé
dans cette responsabilité de ministre
des armées
alors en 2017 lorsque le président de la
république a été élu
la situation de nos armées n'était pas
comparable à celle d'aujourd'hui
le ministère des armées étaient usés
fracturé par des années de fragilisation
cours desquelles nos militaires ainsi
que nos agents civils ont été en proie à
des tendances contraires
à vrai dire un véritable paradoxe que
vous connaissez bien d'un côté des
budgets toujours plus contraint des
réductions drastiques d'effectifs des
unités dissoutes des programmes parfois
volontairement retardé voire dans
certains cas arrêter et puis de l'autre
un besoin et en engagement sans cesse
croissant de nos armées qu'il s'agisse
des opérations extérieures comme sur le
territoire national notre défense était
fort forme fortement pardon sollicité
car la france faisait face à des menaces
qui n'ont fait que s'accentuer c'est ce
que la revue stratégique de 2017 que
nous avons actualisé cette année a
montré
le terrorisme est toujours la menace
numéro un
la compétition stratégique entre les
états s'intensifie en favorisant les
tensions et en poussant certaines
puissances à des stratégies
d'intimidation et de fait accompli et
enfin les menaces installe dans de
nouveaux espaces de conflictuelle it et
dans l'espace le cyber les fonds marins
ou encore dans le champ informationnel
dans ce contexte stratégique en plein
durcissement les tendances contraires
subis par nos armées n'avaient que trop
duré le président de la république a
donc fixé un cap clair que les armées
retrouve pleinement les moyens
d'accomplir leur mission
la loi de programmation militaire 2019
2025 a été la traduction concrète des
engagements pris par le président la
république et on l'a longtemps résumée à
l'idée de porter le budget des armées à
2% du pib à l'horizon 2025
mais il s'agissait et il s'agit toujours
de bien plus que cela il s'agit avant
tout de donner aux armes et les moyens
d'assumer leur mission de toujours
protéger la france et les français
d'ici 2030 la france va pouvoir
intervenir partout où ses intérêts sont
en jeu gagnées sur tous les terrains
l'emportait face à tous les ennemis
seuls ou en coalition et pour réussir ce
défi
nous n'avons qu'une solution
disposer d'un modèle d'armée complet et
équilibré et ce modèle c'est justement
celui que nous construisons que
construit la loi de programmation
militaire depuis désormais trois ans
cette loi de programmation militaire
elle a été une inflexion historique
295 milliards d'euros sur la période 19
25 c'est une ambition sans précédent
pour notre défense lors certains on
raillait en la jugeant irréaliste
certains ont douté des engagements du
président d'autres encore
simplement
conduit par la sagesse de l'expérience
n'envisagez pas la possibilité qu'elle
puisse être respecté et je sais que
beaucoup d'entre vous entre ces murs
pour être attestée des difficultés
récurrentes de respect des lt m au cours
des 25 dernières années
aujourd'hui
les engagements du président de la
république sont tenus et sont tenus
malgré insiste sur ce point une pandémie
qui a durement affecté notre économie
d'autres auraient pu se servir de ce
prétexte pour faire à nouveau de la
défense une variable d'ajustement
cela n'a pas été le cas
c'est donc une fierté de vous présenter
pour la cinquième fois un budget en
hausse qui atteint près de 41 milliards
d'euros qui est strictement conforme à
la loi de programmation militaire qui
fixe est une un objectif ambitieux à
savoir une augmentation du budget de
l'ordre de 1 milliard sept depuis que
celle ci a été votée je rappelle la
séquence des chiffres parce que
avant 2019 il y a eu 2018 et donc en
2018 le projet de loi de finances après
prévu une progression de 1 milliard 800
millions d'euros par rapport à 2010 est
et depuis 2010 9 chaque année 1 milliard
700 millions d'euros ont été ajoutées
année après année si bien que depuis
2010 est si l'on raisonne en cumul cela
représente 26 milliards de plus pour nos
armées soit l'équivalent de presque 3
ans du budget consacré aux programmes
d'équipements majeurs
je rappelle que lorsque j'ai été nommé
ministre en 2017 le budget de la défense
était de 32,3 milliards d'euros en 2022
il s'élèvera à 40 9 milliards la
progression est évidemment extrêmement
significatif alors c'est vrai aussi que
nature humaine s'habitue à tout en
particulier lorsqu'il s'agit d'une
augmentation des moyens et des capacités
qui ont été durement acquise
j'insiste donc sur le fait que ce budget
n'est pas un budget ordinaire
une augmentation de près de 2 milliards
d'euros cette extraordinaire et ce
budget continue donc de traduire sur le
terrain nos engagements vis-à-vis des
français vis-à-vis des militaires et des
civils qui assure notre défense
il s'agit de la quatrième année de mise
en oeuvre de la lpm ce n'est donc pas le
moment de faiblir puisque nous n'en
sommes qu'à la moitié
ce budget 2022 continue de répondre aux
quatre priorités de la lpm vous les
connaissez par coeur mais ne résiste pas
à la tentation de les énumérer de
nouveau la première c'est d'améliorer le
quotidien de celles et ceux qui choisit
de servir la france de leur offrir des
conditions de vie et d'exercice de leur
métier à la hauteur de leur engagement
la deuxième c'est de renouveler tous les
équipements usées est vieillissant de
nos armées et d'améliorer la
disponibilité de tous nos matériels car
on ne gagne pas les conflits du 21e
siècle avec des blindés indisponible des
années 70 la troisième priorité c'est de
construire notre autonomie stratégique à
un niveau européen
c'est essentiel si la france veut
conserver sa liberté d'action pour
protéger efficacement ses citoyens et la
quatrième priorité c'est enfin d'innover
et de bâtir les armées du futur pour
répondre aux défis de demain alors avant
d'entrer dans le détail je vous propose
de préciser les domaines qui
bénéficieront de cette croissance d'1
milliard 7,2 l'année
2022 par rapport à 2021 donc ce
milliards 7 de croissance est consacré à
hauteur de 500 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui iront donc au
programme d'armement majeurs dont la
dotation sera ainsi porté à 8 milliard
cent millions
pour 300 millions d'euros
supplémentaires à l'entretien programmé
du matériel ce qui portera la dotation à
4,4 milliards d'euros illustrant la
priorité que nous avons mises à
l'amélioration de la disponibilité de
ces matériels
300 millions d'euros de plus iront à la
dissuasion ce qui portera le
les moyens affectés à la dissuasion à 5
milliards 300 millions
200 millions d'euros de plus efront aux
dépenses consacrées aux autres
équipements 100 millions d'euros de plus
seront consacrés à l'innovation
et 300 millions d'euros de plus seront
consacrés à la masse salariale
normalement si j'ai bien compté nous
devrions retrouver le milliard sept que
je décrivais alastair
alors si j'en viens maintenant de
manière un peu plus détaillée au contenu
du budget 2022 je commencerai par
l'amélioration du quotidien de nos
soldats nous avons fait beaucoup de
chemin nous avons aujourd'hui des
militaires mieux équipée mieux préparés
et mieux protégés sur le terrain ainsi
que des familles de militaires mieux
soutenus et mieux logés et nous allons
continuer en ce sens en 2022 près de 2
milliards d'euros seront donc consacrés
à des mesures à hauteur d'homme dont 1,6
milliard qui concerne les petits
équipements du quotidien leur livraison
va se poursuivre avec
les fusils d'assaut 12000 sont attendus
en 2022 ce qui depuis 2010 cette porte
le nombre leur nombre à 53 mille
soixante dix mille treillis de nouvelle
génération ce qui depuis 2010 cette
porte leur nombre à près de deux cent
soixante cinq mille 5000 gilet pare
balles seront livrés portant le nombre
total des livraisons à 65 milles depuis
2000 17 34 milles équipements de
protection individuelle nrbc ce qui
représente une très forte accélération
puisque 2002 puis 2017 nous en aurons
mise en service 55000 mais aussi des
jumelles de vision nocturne des armes de
poing des couteaux de combat et j'arrête
là l'énumération
autre point important dans cette
rubrique à hauteur d'homme c'est
évidemment le plan famille en 2022 nous
donnerons un nouvel élan à ce plan en
portant une nouvelle ambition pour
l'hébergement et le logement des
militaires et de leurs familles
depuis 2010 est
près de 2500 chambres ont été rénovées
ou construites en caserne militaire et
415 logements neufs ont été livrés
partout en france la crise sanitaire a
pu parfois malheureusement avoir pour
effet de décaler certaines livraisons
mais je puis vous dire que les acteurs
mettent les bouchées doubles pour
permettre à nos personnels de disposer
de conditions d'hébergement et de
logement digne de ce qu'on est en droit
d'attendre quand on s'engage pour son
pays donc en 2022 nous consacrerons
337 millions d'euros à l'hébergement et
au logement et puis où vous l'avez
peut-être
juste nous avons annoncé hier que nous
étions en train de finaliser la
contractualisation
pour
permettre
l'externalisation de la gestion des
logements domaniaux du ministère des
armées ce projet s'appelle ambitions
logement nous devrions notifié ce
contrat en 2022 et ce contrat permettra
non seulement la rénovation mais aussi
la construction de logements neufs aux
meilleurs standards de confort avec des
matériaux de qualité et permettant de
générer des économies d'énergie pour les
locataires et ce partout en france donc
dès 2022 nous engageons dès lors que le
contrat aura été notifié nous lancerons
la construction de 3000 logements pour
disposer à terme d'un parc de 15 mille
logements domaniaux ce qui permettra
notamment de proposer une offre en zone
tendue c'est donc parmi les différentes
mesures
à hauteur d'homme une mesure phare qui
nous engage pour les 35 prochaines
années et qui bénéficiera tantôt
militaire qu'au civil du ministère des
armées et puis bien sûr dans le cadre de
scènes de ce même plan famille nous
continuerons de déployer le wifi gratuit
sur nos emprises d'ouvrir ces espaces
francs service des militaires que l'on
appelle les espaces atlas partout en
france en outre mer ainsi qu'à
l'étranger et puis et puis également
d'ouvrir des crèches car ce point là
n'est peut être pas apparu de façon très
saillantes mais depuis 2017 nous avons
créé plus de 1000 places en crèche
dépassant ainsi de très loin l'objectif
que nous nous étions fixés qui était de
265 donc nous sommes très au delà et en
2022 nous créerons à nouveau 120 places
supplémentaires répartis entre cherbourg
toulon cayenne mont-de-marsan autant de
villes qui sont clés pour nos armées
enfin nous consacrerons
170 millions d'euros à la fidélisation
des talents ce qu'ils sont vous le savez
la richesse de ce ministère est donc
dans la continuité des travaux que nous
avons conduit l'an dernier nous
poursuivrons la mise en oeuvre de la
nouvelle politique de rémunération des
militaires la npr m c'est une réforme
que vous connaissez qui restructure en
profondeur la rémunération de nos
militaires pour en améliorer la
lisibilité
pour prendre également en compte la
spécificité de leurs engagements et
s'adapter à la politique de ressources
humaines et aux besoins de notre
ministère c'était devenu indispensable
au regard de la complexité du système
actuel ainsi 70 millions d'euros
supplémentaires seront consacrés en 2022
pour intégrer au titre de la deuxième
vague de déploiement de l'aide prm les
contraintes d'absence opérationnel mais
aussi les niveaux de responsabilité
ainsi que de performances il s'ensuivra
une augmentation sensible du niveau de
rémunération nos militaires
cette augmentation est parfaitement
justifiée et elle témoigne de la
reconnaissance de la nation pour ceux
qui assurent sa protection
en tout temps et en tout lieu
au delà près de 48 millions d'euros
seront consacrés à des mesures
catégorielles pour améliorer la
fidélisation et l'attractivité des
carrières notamment des contractuels
spécialistes dont les talents sont
essentiels le mystère des armes et
contribuera enfin comme
les autres ministères mais c'est inédit
à la protection sociale complémentaire
de ses personnels et ceci pour un
montant total de 50 millions d'euros
c'est la première étape du déploiement
de la prise en charge progressive par
l'employeur du coup de cette protection
sociale complémentaire
j'en viens au deuxième chapitre le
renouvellement des équipements de nos
armées cette année sera encore marquée
par d'importantes livraisons de
matériels et d'équipements majeurs et
vous le constater chaque jour sur le
terrain la lpm porte déjà ses fruits les
matériels dans nos forces ont tant
besoin arrive au sein des unités et
c'est le résultat d'un investissement
sans faille des personnels du ministère
ainsi que des industriels ces derniers
mois ils ont redoublé d'efforts je pense
notamment aux 32 véhicules blindés
griffon qui ont été déployés au sahel je
pense aux livraisons qui se poursuivent
la première frégate multimissions à
capacités de défenses aériennes
renforcée qui a été livré à la marine en
avril dernier les 150 derniers ensembles
de parachutage du combattant qui ont été
livrés à l'armée de terre qui en dispose
désormais de 15 milles et puis tout
récemment un cinquième a330 mrtt phoenix
qui est venu compléter la flotte de la
31ème escadre aérienne de ravitaillement
et transport stratégique à istres
2022 sera à nouveau marquée par un
important volume de livraison comme la
liste est longue je ne mentionnerai qu'à
titre d'exemple la livraison de la
dernière fremm de défense aérienne la
lorraine pour la marine la livraison de
1500 nouveaux véhicules dont 245 blindés
scorpions pour l'armée de terre
et puis trois nouveaux avions
ravitailleurs américains phoenix pour
l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
renouveler nos matériels c'est aussi
assurer leur maintien en conditions
opérationnelles et renouveler nos
infrastructures
la réforme du m6 aéronautique se
poursuivra en 2022 pour relever le
niveau de disponibilité qui continue de
s'améliorer et d'ailleurs on l'a vu dans
le cadre de l'opération apag en
300 millions d'euros supplémentaires je
les lis à l'instance seront consacrés en
plus à l'entretien des matériels en 2022
et enfin nous consacrerons 2 milliards
400 millions au développement et au
maintien en condition de nos
infrastructures
notamment pour l'accueil de nos nouveaux
équipements j'en viens au troisième axe
de la lpm la consolidation de notre
autonomie stratégique à laquelle ce
budget pour 2022 contribuer tout d'abord
les efforts nécessaires à la dissuasion
nucléaire seront poursuivis
cela concerne les travaux de
renouvellement des deux composante
aéroportée et océaniques et ce sont donc
5 milliard 300 millions d'euros qui
seront consacrés en 2022 à la dissuasion
dans le domaine spatial pendant dans le
domaine conventionnel précisément je
voulais souligner les développements
dans le domaine spatial
646 millions d'euros seront affectés au
soutien de la stratégie spatiale les
programmes en cours de réalisation se
concrétiseront en 2022 par la livraison
de quelques capacités majeurs notamment
un nouveau satellite de
télécommunications syracuse 4 une
capacité spéciale de renseignement
électromagnétique
qui sera donc unique au niveau européen
est le troisième satellite la composante
cso d'observation optique
par ailleurs le commandement de l'espace
et le centre d'excellence autant
monteront en puissance
ce commandement de l'espace bénéficiera
de 48 effectifs supplémentaires et
atteindra 3 137 postes et par ailleurs
nous affecterons 10 personnels français
dans le centre d'excellence de l'otan à
toulouse dès l'été 2022 dans le cadre de
la la préfiguration de ce centre nous
lancerons les travaux d'infrastructure
qui sont associés à toulouse en
intégrant une nouvelle dynamique que
naisse défense pour mettre en oeuvre la
stratégie de défense spatial que j'ai eu
l'occasion de présenter en 2019 je pense
aussi à l'effort d'accélération dans le
domaine de la cyber défense
376 nouveaux postes seront consacrés à
ce chant et enfin dans le domaine du
renseignement
ce sont 3 199 millions d'euros qui
seront consacrés au domaine du
renseignement
vous avez monsieur le président
mentionné le l'autonomie stratégique
européenne et son développement cela
reste un objectif majeur auquel
ministère des armées oeuvre rats dans le
cadre de la présidence française de
l'union européenne
le fonds européen de défense doit
permettre de passer à l'échelle dans le
développement de l'industrie de défense
européenne en 2022 1 milliard 200
millions seront alloués au lancement de
nouveaux projets européens il faut se
souvenir que cela représentait seulement
un peu plus de 200 millions en 2019
dans ces conditions fort des succès déjà
remportés par l'industrie française le
mystère des armées sera force de
proposition notamment dans les domaines
du combat aérien du combat terrestre de
la résilience énergétique et de la
transition environnementale
enfin c'est le quatrième axe de notre
lpm s'agit de la préparation de l'avenir
est bien là aussi les engagements pris
seront tenus nous tiendrons les
objectifs qui avaient été annoncés de 1
milliard d'euros consacré à l'innovation
pour concevoir les technologies de
demain donc nous étions
dans la période 2014 2019 autour de 730
millions d'euros par an consacrés à
l'innovation nous franchissons un seuil
avec ce milliard à compter de 2022 ce
qui nous permettra de répondre à la
diversité des défis que suscite la
construction du futur de notre défense
aussi bien pour les bras la préparation
des grands programmes structurants dont
nous avons maintes fois parlé que pour
toutes les technologies émergentes je
pense aux technologies quantiques je
pense à la lutte anti drones je pense
aux armes à énergie dirigée par exemple
et sans être exhaustive bien entendu je
signale également que 2022 sera l'année
de la montée en puissance du fonds
innovation défense doté de 200 millions
d'euros pour soutenir le développement
de technologies dual qui sont portées
par des petites entreprises françaises
innovantes
j'insiste sur un dernier point qui n'est
pas le moindre ce budget 2022 qui
atteint près de 41 milliards d'euros
bénéficie tout entier au soutien de
l'économie française nous avons eu
l'occasion d'en parler à plusieurs
reprises la lpm c'est un plan de relance
à elle seule
ce budget irrigue l'ensemble des
territoires avec 36 milliards d'euros de
commandes qui seront passés l'année
prochaine et qui viendront donc soutenir
notre économie et pour mémoire la bcdc
plus de 200000 emplois partout en france
nous serons encore en 2022 le premier
recruteur de france avec plus de 26000
recrutements programmés
et enfin je rappelle la mobilisation
constante de notre ministère dans le
cadre de la crise sanitaire et de la
crise économique avec le plan de soutien
à l'aéronautique et dans le cadre du
plan de relance puisque c'est assez peu
connu mais le ministère est lauréat de
plus de 700 projets sur le seul volet
écologie du plan de relance et ceci pour
plus de 200 millions d'euros donc c'est
un apport significatif qui nous est
ainsi apporter produits voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous dire en préambule ce
budget 2022 s'inscrit donc dans la
continuité de l'effort consenti à la
défense depuis 2010 est pour autant il
n'en est pas moins remarquable
remarquable par le montant des crédits
accordés
remarquable par son bénéfice pour notre
économie est remarquable dans sa mise en
oeuvre en totale conformité avec la lpm
et vous pouvez d'ailleurs je me permets
de faire un peu de publicité monsieur le
président vous pouvez en suivre l'état
d'avancement
il suivre l'état d'avancement de la
modernisation de nos armées sur un site
internet dédié qui s'appelle baromètre
de la lpm vous y retrouverez tous les
chiffres les plus emblématiques de cet
lp m avec le rappel des objectifs
initiaux et le niveau d'avancement de
chacune des actions car je tiens à ce
que le ministère des armées comme unique
en toute transparence sur son action
compte tenu de l'effort considérable qui
est consenti pour les français en sa
faveur
le budget 2022 et donc à un budget
fidèles à l'ambition fixée celui d'un
modèle d'armée complet permettant de
mener la mission c'est ce que le
président de la république avait demandé
et la mission elle consiste à protéger
la france et les français aujourd'hui et
demain
c'est un budget qui est ce au service de
ceux qui nous défendent mais c'est un au
travers de ce terme un peu
conceptuel je voudrais surtout dire
qu'il est au service des hommes et des
femmes de nos armées qui se battent pour
nous et pour qui avec beaucoup d'honneur
et de fierté je me bats au quotidien à
vos côtés depuis plus de cinq ans merci
beaucoup de votre attention je suis à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci madame la ministre pour
cette présentation très très clair et
nous vous donnons acte bien évidemment
d'avoir conduit ce ce véritable combat
budgétaire au cours des derniers
exercices est manifestement pour celui
qui s'annonce parce qu'effectivement
grâce à cet effort consenti nos forces
armées sont en passe
de retrouver un
niveau
d'équipement de et de conditions
d'exécution de leurs missions qui change
par rapport à tout ce qui s'était passé
précédemment sans plus attendre je vais
donner la parole à nos d'abord à nos
rapporteur en demandant évidemment à
chacun de ceux
de ne rester que sur la les affaires
budgétaires parce qu'il ya une liste
assez conséquente et de ne pas faire de
questions trop aux dons dans de telle
sorte qu'on ait une discussion qui soit
constructive
je vais donc commencer par les
rapporteurs du 146 et équipements des
forces avec cédric perrin une fois que
j'ai vu arriver
merci monsieur le président le ministre
mes chers collègues madame ministre
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit la
trajectoire budgétaire il est respecté
les premiers résultats arrivent puisque
les premiers matériels commencent à être
livrées dans les forces à la grande
satisfaction de nos deux noms donnés aux
femmes et aux hommes sur sur le terrain
et je crois que dans la continuité de ce
que disait le président nous l'avons
toujours ici dans cette commission
fais en sorte d'être
en tout cas à vos côtés et d'être plus
constructif possible possible les
remarques que nous faisons ont pour
vocation c'est de faire évoluer les
choses ou en tout cas à les améliorer
parce que nous avons la conviction que
ce que nous constatons parfois pourrait
être pourrait être améliorée maintenant
le mist et succès à l'export sont
également au rendez-vous si on excepte
évidemment la tragédie ostré août
australienne de ces dernières de ces
dernières semaines et nous avions nous
vous avions interrogé l'an dernier sur à
la même époque sur l'impact de la vente
d'avions de combat rafale à la grèce la
situation était déjà tendue pour nos
armes et elle est encore davantage
aujourd'hui la croatie a fait part de
son intention d'acheter 12 rafale
d'occasions la grèce a annoncé porter
ses commandes à 24 appareils les
appareils d'occasion sont prélevées
directement dans nos forces mais les
appareils neufs seront prélevés sur nos
commandes ce qui est également
préjudiciable à nos armées aussi pouvait
nous faire un point sur ces prélèvements
et sur les commandes nouvelles effectué
en compensation sur la question du
retour des recettes issues des ventes
d'appareils d'occasion et sur les
décalages entre les prélèvements sur nos
forces et l'arrivée de nouveaux
matériels de nos appareils commandés
comment est ce que sera compensé cette
réduction capacitaire temporaire
ensuite des questions similaires se pose
s'agissant de la vente de trois frégates
et veiller à la grèce contre un nouveau
don nous réjouissons qu'ils doivent
conduire à décaler les livraisons de la
marine à la marine nationale nous nous
réjouissons évidemment je le disais de
nos succès à l'export et de nos
partenariats stratégiques mais comment
mieux les anticiper et trouver des
solutions pour ses succès ce que ces
succès ne pénalise pas nos propres
forces enfin
vous avez mentionné évidemment dans vos
propos liminaire l'amélioration du
quotidien des soldats qui est un point
absolument fondamental non l'a évoqué
ensemble longuement jeudi l'amélioration
du quotidien des soldats c'est
évidemment une vision importante qui
doit être mise sur ce sujet car c'est un
élément je pense absolument fondamental
du moral des troupes on le voit quand on
quand on va les rencontrer je prends
l'exemple on était il ya quelques mois
avec le président et quelques uns de mes
collègues en guyane
on nous a exposé par très simplement
mais le fait que les hamacs qui ont été
libérés sont les matériels qui sont pas
utilisés parce qu'ils sont pas du tout
adaptées aux conditions climatiques et
chacun est obligé de racheter un maxi un
tout petit exemple mais il y en a
d'autres qu'on pourrait citer je pense
qu'il ya un point de vigilance important
à avoir sur ce petit matériel en vous
expliquer qu'ils 2 milliards était
consacré
ah c'est à ces questions et donc on ne
peut évidemment que s'en réjouir mais
j'insiste vraiment sur la nécessité
qu'il y à mon sens en tout cas de
consulter les militaires avant d'aller
livrer du matériel ou même de le
commander je pense que c'est un point
qui pourrait être largement discuté et
débattu mais qui est régulièrement remis
sur la table et dernier point que je
voulais évoquer avec vous il est un peu
plus polémique mais vous savez combien
moi à titre personnel je suis
extrêmement attachée à la à ce conte
dans l'abbaye td on aide aux entreprises
françaises parfois et que dans la
réaction des marché d'appel d'offres on
fasse en sorte aussi que nous voisins ne
s'en prive pas qu'on puisse aussi mais
des critères qui nous permettent
peut-être parfois en tout cas d'acheter
du matériel français et vous savez qu'il
ya un marché en ce moment ce fut marché
les femmes les fusibles dix fusils à
pompe je rappelle quand même que nous
avons
pour des raisons qui sont tout à fait
justifiées privilégié hk et nous avons
sauvé hk ces dernières années je
rappelle qu'il ya dernier manufacturier
français d'armes dont je ne citerai pas
le nom mais 40 difficulté je pense qu'il
serait intéressant que nous puissions de
temps en temps aussi favoriser nos
entreprises certains ne se gênent pas
ailleurs
et ça me semble être un point un point
très important je rappelle que dans le
marché les fusils de précision de
l'armée de terre les entreprises
françaises avaient été exclues au départ
parce qu'elle ne faisait pas de 50
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
dans l'année est de -1 ce qui était un
critère quand même un peu un peu dur à
avaler pour certains qui se faisait
exclure des marchés donc je pense que
parfois on peut aussi essayer d'écrire
des marchés qui permettent aux
entreprises françaises d'être
non pas un choisi mais en tout cas un
minimum de pouvoir compétitionner d'être
des compétiteurs dans les affaires et
dans les marchés qui sont en cours voilà
je ne serai pas plus long parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'autres questions qui
pourraient être posées mais je voulais
au moins avoir ces trois points à mettre
à l'ordre du jour
merci cédric hélène conway pour
compléter sur le cac40 qui disent oui
c'est compliqué avec un seul point
monsieur le président madame la ministre
d'abord nous nous réjouissons des moyens
que vous avez présenté alors autres
auditions finalement et ouvre le bal et
lire le bal des auditions pour nous et
nous allons rentrer dans le détail du
pulse et notamment avec avec votre
équipe donc je n'aurai qu'un qu'une
seule question
qui sort un petit peu du détail
budgétaire puisque cédric est à exprimer
un petit peu les différents
questionnements des sujets d'inquiétude
que nous avons mais matière de bd tout à
fait raison de rappeler combien elle est
importante pour nous il ya un sujet de
préoccupation pour elle qui est le
projet de texte européen visant à
établir des nouveaux critères pour
l'obtention du label écologique pour les
produits financiers vous ai posé une
question écrite il y a quelques mois sur
le sujet
et la réponse ne met pas encore parvenus
et surtout dont chez nos industriels le
questionnement et l'inquiétude grandit
puisque
ce texte se fonde sur un rapport du
centre commun de recherche qui préconise
exclure de ce label les entreprises
impliquées dans la production est et où
le commerce d'armes conventionnelles et
le produit militaire pour le combat si
elle qui a plus de 5% de leurs revenus
de ses activités dont quand on sait
combien les exportations sont
importantes pour l'ensemble de nos
industriels on peut se dire que cette
restriction aurait quand même un impact
incroyablement négatifs sont pas là si
vous pouvez nous nous apporter une
réponse je crois qu'elle serait très
apprécié par notre but est d merci
merci hélène alors je fais maintenant
des la parole aux deux rapporteurs du
144 après les rapporteurs et avant les
autres collègues je vous donnerai la
parole pour nous pas trop mélanger non
plus l'ensemble des sujets au 144e
pascal allizard se
défend merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre effectivement
j'interviens en tant que co rapporteurs
du 144 mais vous me permettrez quelques
mots suite votre présentation les 10
vous-même du dernier budget de ce
quinquennat et pour ma part je voudrais
vous remercier pour votre implication
personnelle est constante depuis votre
nomination sur les efforts concernant ce
que j'appelle l'environnement humain et
professionnel social du soldat je crois
que c'est primordial pour les soldats
bien évidemment mais aussi pour leurs
familles tout au long de leur carrière
quelques mots aussi si vous le permettez
sur les équipements vous venez de nous
détailler les efforts du budget cette
année notamment les petits équipements
au renouvellement de la politique de m c
o c'était nécessaire je pars développer
ce que vient de dire cédric perrin tout
ça va dans le bon sens bien évidemment
mais un point quand même de vigilance
sur toutes ces opérations d'export qui
effectivement sont des succès mais qui
en tout cas peuvent inquiéter aussi
sur les capacités opérationnelles
immédiates et alors que nos déploiements
en opex reste reste quand même intense
un point aussi vous avez obtenus et je
crois qu'on y a beaucoup contribué le
vote d'une nouvelle pm avec un travail
fort de proposition et malheureusement
vous n'avez pas pu appliquer l'article
prévoyant sa révision et j'aurais veut
dire personnellement que je regrette que
le président la république et le premier
ministre et agit ainsi car je pense que
vous-même souhaitiez le respect de la
loi votée et de l'engagement donné et
enfin un dernier point je n'oublie pas
le tournant stratégique concernant
l'armée de l'air intégrant les défis du
spatial car j'estime que cela démontre
la prise en compte de nos besoins de
souveraineté sur ce point voyez même ni
si nous sommes vigilants croyez bien
qu'il s'agit d'une vigilance positive
j'en viens à mes deux questions en fait
j'en ai plus qu'une je vais commencer
par la seconde qui rejoint absolument la
question posée par hélène conway mouret
sur ces textes européens et et les
risques que cela fait porter sur le
financement de la bei t d est une
question un peu plus précise pour le
coup que je vais vous détailler cette
effectivement le budget dédié à
l'innovation vous en avez parlé on
atteint un milliard d'euros pour 2022
c'est une bonne chose mais le diable se
cachant parfois dans les détails nous
avons relevé que le flux de crédit vers
les études amant constat mon pardon
concernant le secteur terrestre
comparativement faible notamment par
rapport aux industries aéronautique et
par rapport aux besoins de l'armée de
terre à moyen terme et notamment dans le
prolongement du programme scorpion mon
attention a été attirée sur le
financement du programme titans qui
prend comprendra notamment le système
blindés lourds mg cs franco allemand le
système d'artillerie et de feu indirects
cfs et contenus la nouvelle doctrine
d'engagement majeur que développe le
chef d'état major des armées ma question
est la suivante ces programmes
justifit-il et sont ils de nature à
rééquilibrer le montant des études amont
vers nos industries terrestre merci
madame
merci pascal pour compléter sur les 144
et niveau grenat oui merci président
madame la ministre plus particulièrement
nos ce domaine du renseignement et des
de la cyberdéfense la loi de
programmation militaire pouvait donc un
renforcement en direction du
renseignement et de la cyberdéfense et
le projet de loi de finances 2009 22
entérine bien c'était fort toutefois
j'aurais de sujets de préoccupation le
premier la lpm puisse un objectif de
1500 équivalents temps plein
supplémentaires en 2025 il y à des
difficultés de recrutement dans le
vivier des sous-officiers désormais et
dans le secteur de la cyberdéfense lui
sur désormais à lancer des campagnes
médiatiques de recrutement notamment
dans le domaine de la sécurité
informatique
fait ce que vous constatez une pénurie
de candidats ou un manque d'attractivité
des conditions de recrutement nous
savons qu'il est très difficile de
maintenir le personnel recruté parfois
pour des raisons tout simplement de
rémunération pouvez vous nous en dire
deux mots
deuxième fois de plus un sujet de
préoccupation
la faire des sous marins australiens
mais aussi les prises de position au
mali récemment 2 jerry met en lumière le
caractère stratégique du renseignement
et notre dépendance relative vis-à-vis
de nos alliés américains
nous entendons ce matin bernard emié
donc directeur général de la dg ceux
qui tout en se félicitant bien sûr des
efforts qui sont faits depuis quelques
années par le par votre ministère
considéré en termes de comparaison que
par rapport à ce que faisait nos amis
britanniques nous n'ayons pas forcément
financièrement au même niveau lanternes
d'équivalents temps plein également en
conséquence nous savons que nous vivions
dans un monde où tout est possible et
pas forcément le meilleur avec parfois
éventuellement des renforcements
d'alliance est-ce que vous pensez que
nos moyens de renseignement aujourd'hui
en nombre de personnels et en moyens
techniques et technologiques
permettent au moment où on parle d'une
autonomie plus forte du renseignement ou
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est préférable
de renforcer encore les phares le 2 nov
les moues faiblir et n'est pas seulement
de continuer cet effort qui est
important mais aussi de renforcer encore
compte tenu de l'environnement
géostratégique auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
merci annie qui nous allons passer aux
178 préparation et emploie des forces
olivier cigolotti merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous l'avez
évoqué cette année le plf pour 2022
prévoit d'attribuer 4 5 milliard d'euros
à l'entretien programmé du matériel est
je crois que nous ne pouvons que nous
réjouir de cette trajectoire qui est
respectée puisque c'est pratiquement 100
millions d'euros de plus que la nuitée
moyenne de 4,4 milliards d'euros fixé
pour le pm dans la loi de programmation
militaire nous pouvons raisonner
autrement que par cette moyenne
mathématique puisque malheureusement
contrairement à ce que nous avions
souhaité nous n'avons pas d'autres
précisions sur le rythme de consommation
de ces crédits au cours de la période de
programmation mais je crois qu'il nous
faut nous nous féliciter effectivement
de 7,2 cette augmentation je vais
revenir nous savons que sur les annuités
à venir nous aurons à faire face à des
besoins importants que la marche 2023
sera importante puisque découleront de
ces besoins l'entretien des matériels
vieillissant qu'il s'agisse d'un aéronef
ou ou de navires mais les crédits
alloués à l'entretien programmé du
matériel sont sont déterminants
puisqu'il un pack très directement le
niveau de disponibilité technique
opérationnelle de l'ensemble de nos
équipements
7 dt au devient désormais une des seules
données dans protégés que nous pourrons
utiliser à l'avenir dans nos débats et
même si au sein notre commission nous
sommes tous très sensibles
au fait de et à la nécessité de protéger
un certain nombre de données
comment est-ce que nous pourrons à nos
ministres à l'avenir faire la part entre
la disponibilité technique
qui est le nombre d'avions qui volent
par an au sein d'une flotte et la dt au
qui prend en compte les impératifs de
maintenance c'est une nuance qui pour
nous va être difficile à analyser et
puis vous me permettrez en deuxième
question de savoir nous avons évoqué les
succès à l'exportation et c'est une
excellente chose en abordant les
contrats avec la grèce et la croatie
dans le même temps la mise en oeuvre du
contrat ravel qui permet l'optimisation
de la maintenance de nos aéronefs permet
effectivement une meilleure
disponibilité technique opérationnelle
en quoi ces contrats grecque et croates
vont-ils impacter la disponibilité
technique puisque nous savons les uns
les autres qu'il nous faut nous préparer
à à la haute intensité et que la
préparation à haute intensité passe bien
sûr par les éléments liés à la
préparation de nos pilotes et notamment
nos pilotes de chasse merci
merci olivier toujours sur les 118 en
complément michel gréau
merci monsieur présidente madame la
ministre tout d'abord je tiens à vous
remercier pour vos paroles que vous avez
eu tout à l'heure en vert les sénatrices
et sénateurs et si de la commission
pour l'être qu'on essaye d'apporter pour
pour la défense de la france
et dans cette optique madame la ministre
le document de présentation de votre
budget met en avant dix points clés
j'aurais souhaité qu'ils en aient 12
pour que soient pris en compte les
besoins de services de soutien et la
nécessité de la remontée de la
préparation opérationnelle
pour le service de santé des armées
l'écart s'est creusé entre le
référentiel en effectif et organisations
de l'hérault et l'effectif réaliser le
déficit est ainsi passé pour les
médecins du premier secours
koné aux côtes 97 postes en 2020 à 136
en 2021 cette évolution est extrêmement
préoccupante ceci conduit à concentrer
sur les mêmes personnels lâchage de
projection de service le taux de
projection des équipes médicales de 125%
malgré l'apport des réservistes a encore
augmenté en 2020 et qu'en est-il en 2021
et quelles sont les prévisions pour 2022
le taux de projection des équipes
chirurgicales atteignaient 200 % en 2020
at il diminué en 2021 et quelles sont
les perspectives pour 2022 le service de
santé malgré cette surcharge a poursuivi
sa participation à l'opération
résilience ne risque-t-on pas de briser
le service de santé des armées outil
d'excellence
à force de trop en demander
pouvez vous nous annoncez des créations
de postes cette année j'ai bien entendu
qu'à 300 millions de réserver pour la
masse salariale enfin comme mon collègue
je m'inquiète des répercussions des
exportations mais pour ma part c'est sur
la préparation opérationnelle que je
m'interroge l'avenant au contrat de
verticalisation de la maintenance des
rafales devraient permettre de maintenir
une d'été aux constantes mais des
progrès étaient attendus pour permettre
la formation en hausse du spectre des
pilotes ces retards fragilise nos
harnais et sont un facteur désincitatif
hors la loi de programmation militaire
au pouce et l'amélioration de la
préparation opérationnelle à la
prochaine période de programmation mais
c'était sans compter la détérioration de
la situation due à ses exportations
imprévus
comment envisagez-vous des remédier sans
attendre 2025 merci
merci michel nous allons passer en
dernier rapport aux 212 soutien de la
politique de défense joël guerriau
alors
bon mais peut-être que marc hier les
deux cas relative c'est en tant que
rapporteur va s'exprimer sur merci merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
tout à l'heure j'ai apprécié que vous
commenciez par l'amélioration du
quotidien du quotidien de nos
combattants ça a été votre première
partie de votre intervention des armées
à hauteur d'homme donc comme nous sommes
chargés avec joël guerriau des
programmes de 112 je crois que c'est
important pour nous une question d'abord
sur le plan de relance de l'économie
vous l'avez évoqué il a permis
d'insuffler de l'argent pour le
ministère des armées comment est-ce
qu'il s'articule entre le plan de
relance lui même et le plf 2022 est-ce
que vous pouvez nous garantir qu'il
s'agit véritablement d'une augmentation
réalié montant et non pas d'une
réaffectation des sommes qui finalement
se cacherait sous un titre aguicheur qui
s'appellerait france relance et là
dedans comment vous pouvez nous dire
qu'est ce qui aurait été retenue pour le
programme 212 vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure des appels à projets vous avez
parlé de 700 je crois appel à projets
certains et la grosse majorité relève de
documents de lignes stratégiques comme
le cyber et autres qu'en est il des
programmes de 112 je sais qu'il y avait
une priorité qui avait été fixé à
l'intérieur sur le verdissement des
hébergements donc ça veut dire parce que
ça ça avance est ce qu'il ya des choses
qui ont été retenus et donc ça de voeux
devrait venir en plus de ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure c'est à dire de
la réhabilitation et de la construction
de logement et d'hébergement et pas en
complément donc deuxième non le coc vide
a fait qu'il ya eu beaucoup de retard et
est ce que vous pensez que cette année
on va pouvoir rétablir établir le retard
est rattrapé un peu le pas ce que
beaucoup de projets sont restés en
instance une toute dernière question
vous avez reçu le 15ème rapport
thématique du haut comité d'évaluation
de la condition militaire récemment il
nous a été présenté mais aussi avec le
président de la commission il ce rapport
met l'accent sur la reconversion des
trente mille militaires qui quitte le
service des armes chaque année c'est
énorme je ne voyais pas autant en tout
cas il je voudrais savoir quelle suite
vous comptez donner aux préconisations
qui ont lieu dans ce rapport notamment
sur l'évaluation de la reconversion d'un
politique de reconversion des armées sur
l'accompagnement de nos militaires
blessés je crois que c'est très
important et qui sont handicapés au
conflit chico moteur d'ailleurs et sur
le suivi individualisé de nos militaires
voilà mes deux questions merci madame la
ministre voilà merci chers collègues
rapporteur on va je vais donner la
parole à madame la ministre tout de
suite et puis je prendrai quatre
questions complémentaires à une minute
chacun après les explications de la
ministre madame la ministre vous avez un
panel de questions sur les principaux
programmes
vous écoutent tous merci beaucoup
monsieur le président je me permettrai
si vous le voulez bien de commencer par
la question plus large que vous avez
posé sur le mali avant de répondre aux
questions qui concerne très directement
public et
nous avons eu à plusieurs reprises
l'occasion de présenter
la manière dont l'opération barkan se
transforme au mali le président la
république après de longues
consultations avec les partenaires du g
500 consultations qui ont eu lieu en
amont du sommet de n'djamena s'était
donc au tout début de l'année 2021
présent la république qui souhaitait que
nous puissions adapter notre dispositif
avait si vous vous en souvenez
accepté de différer la mise en oeuvre de
cette transformation de l'opération
barkan de quelques mois afin que les
pays concernés puissent s'adapter en
connaissance de cause à 7 à cette
volonté de transformation qui ne
signifie en rien que la france quitte le
sahel ou que la france qui peut malige
un tiens à insister sur ce point parce
que évidemment dans la communication qui
est
effectué en ce moment par les autorités
maliennes ceci fait est au coeur au fond
de la désinformation qui est à l'oeuvre
donc nous ne quittons pas le mali et
ce n'est pas au moment où
notre 52e militaire français a perdu la
vie en combattant le terrorisme
que nous donnons la preuve d'un
quelconque
désengagement nous continuons à
combattre le terrorisme et nous
continuons de payer le prix du sang pour
cela
[Musique]